قال الرئيس بايدن هذا الأسبوع إن
الوقت قد حان لإعادة التفكير في علاقة الولايات المتحدة
بالمملكة العربية السعودية بعد أن انحازوا
إلى روسيا لخفض إنتاج النفط ، أحد
الأشياء التي يدفعها بعض زملائك الديمقراطيين في
الكابيتول هيل هو وقف
المبيعات المسلحة المستقبلية للسعودية ،
هل يمكنك إعطاء سبب.  لماذا تريد الولايات المتحدة
مواصلة بيع الأسلحة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية في
الوقت الحالي ،
حسنًا أولاً ، شكرًا دانا على استضافتي
لأنك على حق ، قال الرئيس
إنه سيعيد تقييم
علاقتنا مع المملكة العربية السعودية لأنهم
وقفوا إلى جانب روسيا ضد
المصالح  من الشعب الأمريكي ، هذه
علاقة تم بناؤها على مدى
عقود على أساس الحزبين ، وبالتالي
لن يتصرف الرئيس بشكل
متسرع ، بل سيتصرف بشكل
منهجي بشكل
استراتيجي وسيأخذ وقته للتشاور مع
أعضاء من كلا الطرفين وأيضًا
لإتاحة الفرصة للكونغرس للعودة حتى
يتمكن من الجلوس معهم شخصيًا
والعمل من خلال المكتب لوقف الأسلحة بما في
ذلك
كما كنت أقول للتو أن هذه الخيارات
تشمل تغييرات في نهجنا تجاه
المساعدة الأمنية للمملكة العربية السعودية ،
لكنني لن أتقدم على
الرئيس ، ما سأقوله هو أنه
لا يوجد شيء يتحرك الآن قريبًا ، لذلك
هناك وقت له للحصول على هذه
المشاورات لاتخاذ القرارات التي تصب
في مصلحة الشعب الأمريكي
وهذا ما سيفعله